mais tout d'abord quelques mots
concernant le déplacement jeudi soir du
ministre de l'intérieur dans les
yvelines bernard cazeneuve était à
marly-le-roi pour l'inauguration des
nouveaux locaux du centre de déminage
plusieurs annonces dans le cadre du plan
déminage 2020 et des moyens
supplémentaires seront alloués et
concernant l'euro de football
elle les agents seront fortement
mobilisés on écoute le ministre au micro
de william l vous serez bien sûr tout
particulièrement sollicités dans le
cadre de l'euro 2016 puisque vous aurez
la responsabilité de sécuriser
l'ensemble des stades et des fans zone
mais aussi des camps de base des hôtels
de transfert et des moyens de transport
utilisés par les équipes qui
participeront à cet événement sportif
d'ampleur internationale
j'ajoute que durant toute la durée de la
compétition
des démineurs issus de pays participants
notamment l'italie et l'espagne
viendront également nous prêter leur
concours et en force des équipes j'ai
également pris la décision de vous
autoriser à porter une arme
dans le cadre de vos missions
comme vos collègues policiers vous
intervenez très souvent sur des
situations complexes dans des
circonstances difficiles souvent hostile
et tout comme vous pouvez être la cible
de la haine et de la violence au simple
motif que vous porter l'uniforme et que
par là même vous incarnez la force
publique que vous incarnez l'état de
droit